[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us on eight news now at five i'm bryan
loftis breaking right now a woman is
dead after her son stabbed her inside an
east valley apartment happened about 11
a.m right near nellis and vegas valet
that's where you find 8 news now
investigator david charns david joining
us live with the latest
police say a son in his 30's stabbed a
woman his mother who is in her 70's they
say it happened at this apartment
complex behind me we are live at pacific
harbors near vegas valley and nellis in
the far east valley police say they were
called here after another family member
called 9-1-1 saying the suspect was
acting erratic in that there were knives
inside this apartment that suspect would
not come out and swat came in that
suspect eventually did come out of an
apartment here police say he was covered
in blood and was holding knives in his
hands right now police are trying to
interview him as they process this
apartment for other evidence
right now we don't have to have the
motive we have him in custody we know
that there was
some type of
verbal altercation that occurred which
obviously then turned physical and then
the knives came into play in this
particular incident
now this marking yet another incident of
domestic related violence a domestic
related homicide in our valley
investigators always reminding you there
is help available if you need it police
telling us they will be here throughout
the night processing the scene trying to
get more information and we could learn
the identities of both the victim and
the suspect as early as tonight or
tomorrow morning we are live near vegas
valley in nellis i'm david charns 8 news
now
the